la cathédrale d'Orléans et la rue Jeanne
d'Arc tout un symbole c'est un lieu de
passage et la vitrine d'une marque créée
sous la Révolution française
malgré leur matinale la boutique reçoit
déjà ses premières clients deux
assortiments de Boutard pour des amis
qui nous reçoivent en Vendée ce weekend
donc ça devient un cadeau très très chic
les gens manquent de moutarde ont plus
de la moutarde d'Orléans j'habite
Orléans donc voilà ça fait plaisir
grâce aux transports maritime le
vinaigre la moutarde et les cornichons
ont longtemps fait la réputation de
cette maison avant qu'elle ne sombre
dans une léthargie victime de la
concurrence du train
vous avez du coup la traditionnelle qui
sera là
oui curry curcuma ou après miel et
Chardonnay qui a été très connue pendant
longtemps sous le nom de dimanche en
famille certains rayons sont dégarnis
preuve que la moutarde est devenue
tendance il y a même une tension sur le
produit
j'essaie d'acheter vraiment que du local
surtout au niveau alimentaire parce que
on connaît le savoir-faire de la région
de cette entreprise qui est très très
ancienne et en plus le producteur de
moutarde et de la région de Pithiviers
enfin c'est vraiment du Loiret et je
veux continuer je veux absolument que
cette entreprise perdure produire et
consommer local du 100% made in France
du patriotisme économique ces vendeurs
et c'est dans l'air du temps on a plus
du tout de grands pots d'époque on
faisait pour les restaurateurs et on
avait avant aussi des tout petits pots
qui faisaient 95 grammes qu'on ne
produit plus actuellement on avait aussi
des pots de 22 g qui s'offraient
facilement qu'on ne peut plus en ce
moment fabriquer et façon aussi très peu
demandé puisque les gens ont besoin de
grandes quantités changements de cadre
nous sommes dans le saint du saint la
caverne dalibaba la récolte a été
excellente près de 800 tonnes de graines
de moutarde récoltes faut savoir qu'on
faisait de la moutarde à Orléans depuis
le 14e 15e siècle tout ça parce que on
avait déjà les ingrédients principaux de
la moutarde à savoir le vinaigre et les
graines de moutarde on a fait le choix
de ne pas transiger sur notre processus
de fabrication quitte à avoir quelques
clients mécontents parce que ils ne
seront pas servis aussi vite qu'il le
souhaitent mais au-delà de cette épice
phénomène
de rupture sur sur la moutarde sur le
marché français on a fait le choix de
continuer dans la lignée de la qualité
et de ne faire aucun compromis sur le
processus de fabrication et donc la
qualité des moutarde qui sortent de nos
ateliers depuis la il y a trois ans de
la Maison Martin pourray la production
est passée de 150 000 pots de moutarde à
000 et ce n'est pas fini